[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon ami m'avait promis de m'emmener
promener au bord de l'eau mon pied fit
un écart je suis
tombé croyez-vous qu'il me sauva il ne
m'aimait pas assez et le courant
m'emporta depuis le temps a
passé moi je suis faite pour
dormir
au fil de l'eau qui se
défile et rien ne peut me
retenir à part mon sommeil
tranquille aux herbes rouges de
l'été j'aimais les ma chevelures blondes
elles ne m'ont jamais
réveillé
de cette course en eau
profondee mon ami a tout perdu car je
vais me marier à un poisson
Shadow de
qualité il vaut mes amants pêcheurs mes
amoureux
mariniers et il a plus de pudeur que
tous
lescafandriers moi je suis faite pour
dormir au fil de l'eau qui se
défile et rien ne peut me
retenir à part mon sommeil
[Musique]
tranquille aux herbes rouges de
l'été j'aimé les ma chevelure
blonde
elles ne m'ont jamais
[Musique]
réveillé de cette course en eau
profond mon ami voici 100 ans que je
dors au fond de
l'eau comme la Belleau bois dormant de
la légende et il faut qu'on me chante à
haute voix afin qu' pr ce
nouveau de mon mari poisson prenne la
place
[Musique]
aussitôt arriverai-je un jour
enfin à l'autre bout du
paysage o me faudra-t-il un
matin à nouveau changer de
visage j'ai vu ce que je devais
voir
et tant de choses à mon
oreille sont revenus me dire ce
soir que j'allais renaître au
[Musique]
soleil